After a long, tense wait, the final season
of Game of Thrones finally premiered on April
14, 2019, with the first episode coming in
at just under an hour — despite being packed
full of revelations, reunions, and more.
The return of Jon Snow, Daenerys Targaryen,
the three living Lannisters, and a metric
ton more of the show's characters brought
a few answers and even more questions with
them.
Questions like...did you catch when Mac from
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia showed up?
Here's everything else of importance that
happened in the Game of Thrones season premiere
— and everything we still want to know for
the remaining episodes of the series.
The trailers leading up to the premiere offered
plenty of shots of Daenerys arriving at Winterfell,
and audiences didn't have to wait long — in
the very first shot of the season premiere,
a Winterfell boy climbs a tree to see Daenerys'
army arrive, with the Mother of Dragons and
her right-hand man, Jon Snow, flanked by dragons,
Unsullied, and Dothraki as they arrive at
the stronghold of the North.
Appropriately for the chilly North, the welcome
is less than warm, considering Northerners
are instinctively distrustful of any foreigners,
especially a new Queen from the far South
with two enormous dragons.
It isn't just the townspeople who don't trust
Daenerys.
Sansa, Jon's sister, immediately dislikes
the Dragon Queen, who she considers at once
naive and arrogant for trusting Cersei to
serve as an ally to the North.
Whatever Sansa's attitude might be, it's clear
that Daenerys' assimilation into the Northern
way of life won't be simple, and will likely
be a struggle for the rest of the season.
Cersei Lannister is always one of the toughest
characters to read, and in the premiere, she's
just as inscrutable as ever.
Still astride the Iron Throne, she seems completely
unperturbed by news that the White Walkers
have breached the Wall, especially considering
that the Golden Company, an army of mercenaries
under Cersei's control, has just arrived at
King's Landing thanks to her unlikely fiancé,
Euron Greyjoy.
After he delivers her new army, the two finally
consummate their relationship, which leads
to probably one of the least sexy post-romance
lines you'll hear all week:
"I'm going to put a prince in that belly."
As you might expect, the icy queen looks pretty
uncomfortable, sipping a glass of wine as
he leaves the room.
Last season, audiences heard Cersei tell Jamie
she was pregnant with Jaime's baby.
"Who will you say is the father?"
"You."
Meanwhile, Tyrion found out about his new
niece or nephew a couple episodes later.
That unborn child still seems to be a secret.
So after she drove Jamie to abandon her at
the end of season 7, Cersei may manipulate
Euron into being the next man to unwittingly
claim one of Jaime and Cersei's kids as his
own.
Whether Cersei is creeped out by her new boyfriend
— or if she's planning to pull a Maury and
tell Euron he's the father — we'll just
have to wait for a future episode to find
out.
The most brutal reveal regarding Cersei ultimately
comes from Qyburn, her resident mad scientist,
who shows up during one of Bronn's routine
brothel visits to casually tell him that Cersei
would like both of her brothers dead, and
the one to do it would be rewarded beyond
his wildest dreams.
Cersei obviously has a plan in place, but
how it will unfold is still anyone's guess.
Ever since viewers found out the truth about
Jon's parents — that he was actually born
to a legally married Lyanna Stark and Rhaegar
Targaryen, making him an undisputed prince
— fans have been waiting for Jon to find
out too, and this episode got right to the
point.
Aside from plenty of pointed comments about
who Jon "is," there's one huge moment in this
episode hinting at Jon's true heritage, followed
by the big reveal that finally puts one of
the show's biggest revelations in front of
the person it'll affect the most.
Jon, still blissfully ignorant to the fact
that he's been sleeping with his aunt —
— is having a lovely day-date with his new
girlfriend until she suggests that they ride
her two remaining dragons.
With Daenerys riding Drogon, the dragon she
always takes into battle, Jon is left with
Rhaegal, who is actually named for his father,
Daenerys' brother Rhaegar.
In the moment, it feels especially significant
that Rhaegal allows Jon to mount without protest.
However, at the end of the episode, the show
does away with all pretense that it will keep
this secret, letting Sam tell Jon the entire
truth about who he is, much to Jon's shock
— and naturally, it all happens right in
front of Ned Stark's statue in the crypt.
Reunions between favorite characters rank
among the most important and anticipated moments
in this season, and the premiere certainly
didn't disappoint — even though some of
them weren't particularly happy.
Arya and Jon's reunion at the Godswood in
Winterfell was certainly one of the episode's
most emotional moments, even giving the two
a minute to compare their swords.
Meanwhile, another brother — Theon — showed
up in the eleventh hour to rescue his sister
Yara, who eventually showed her gratitude
in the most Greyjoy way possible:
Ser Jorah Mormont also got the chance to thank
Sam Tarly, who once cured him of greyscale,
though their reunion took a pretty sour turn
once Daenerys let Sam know what she did to
the rest of his family last season.
"Drakaris."
The reunion between Sansa and Tyrion was almost
as tense, since Sansa doesn't believe in him
or his plans anymore.
Another tense reunion took place between Jon
and Sam, especially since a hysterical Sam
holds the key to Jon's parentage and is fresh
off the discovery that he's now the only Tarly
man left.
However, the most fraught was definitely between
Jaime Lannister and Bran Stark once the former
arrives at Winterfell, considering that Jaime
last saw Bran when he pushed him out a window
and tried to kill him in the very first episode.
Audiences haven't seen Tormund Giantsbane
— everyone's favorite red-headed wildling
— since he was spotted at Eastwatch last
season as the Wall melted around him, so fans
were likely thrilled to see both Tormund and
Beric Dondarrion alive but not particularly
well at another Northern castle, trying to
figure out how many dead they had to deal
with and whether or not the army was close
by.
Ultimately, they find the body of young Ned
Umber, the tiny leader of the House Umber,
pinned to the wall and surrounded by dismembered
limbs in a spiral pattern, which Beric notes
is a "message" from the Night King.
Spiral patterns shouldn't surprise any loyal
Game of Thrones viewers, especially not where
White Walkers are concerned — in the very
first episode, the Walkers arranged the limbs
of their victims into a circular pattern somewhat
reminiscent of the one that includes poor
dead Ned.
They can also be seen using dead horses to
draw their spiral sign in season 3, when Jon
and the Wildlings go to the Fist of the First
men.
"Always the artists"
So what does the spiral mean?
Well, it's pretty simple.
This is the Night King's way of telling the
armies of Westeros:
"Hold onto your butts.”
The White Walkers are coming, and probably
in the very next episode.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.